étranger
il y a différentes façons de faire des films
qui ont des personnages CG ce qui nous
intéresse avec la capture de performance
est la totalité de la Performance
Physique émotionnel facial les yeux
tout ce que l'acteur crée l'émotion que
l'acteur crée au moment où c'est notre
travail de s'assurer que  tout ce que l'
acteur a fait est préservé dans leur
personnage CG tu es très dur avec
eux
je suis le père c'est mon travail tout ce
que Jake Sully en tant que navi fait Sam a
fait
[Musique]
tu peux capturer l'émotion tu peux
capturer les subtilités les nuances
des mouvements vous pouvez capturer l'œil
et capturer les tiques tout
capturer tout je serai gentil une fois
puis je ne le serai pas
au moment où je l'ai vue pour la première fois
j'étais comme tu es tellement belle le
bleu n'a jamais regardé  plus beau
la chose étonnante est que la technologie
me donne ce portail pour amener mon moi de 14
ans à jouer cette fille les avatars ne
lâchent pas
et faire un tournage de film sur Pandora
n'existe pas les avatars  n'existent pas à
neuf pieds de haut, nous avons des acteurs travaillant dans
un volume avec des marqueurs sur leur corps
des hedricks faciaux sur leur tête et nous
capturons cent pour cent de leur
performance dans le monde numérique au
début de la journée, la première chose que nous
faisons est  entrez dans la combinaison de capture de performance
et c'est un deux pièces moulant
et il est totalement rempli de
piscines de type ping-pong autour de nous afin qu'ils puissent
ensuite suivre mon bras et ensuite traduire
cela dans le monde virtuel, ils ont
toutes ces petites caméras qui envoient  ces
petits rayons qui donnent une image de vous en
mouvement donc chaque petit mouvement
est votre mouvement et ensuite nous mettons
un casque et c'est un casque et il a
une caméra qui est juste devant votre
visage une des grandes avancées que nous  'ai
fait technologiquement sur les suites est
la capture de performance faciale que nous
capturons une fidélité de performance beaucoup plus élevée
mais je sais une chose
[Musique]
cette famille est notre forteresse
J'ai fait beaucoup d'écran vert j'ai
fait beaucoup d'écran bleu mais jamais
quelque chose comme ça bien sûr où il n'y a
vraiment pas d'écran vous agissez juste
dans un espace non vous devez rester
avec nous
j'ai toujours pensé qu'être dans le
volume c'est jouer et Imagination
et là  n'y a pas de peur ou de honte,
vous pouvez faire tout ce que vous devez faire pour
arriver à cette vérité en sauvant leur vie,
c'est tout ce qui compte J'ai dû
travailler complètement différemment de ce que j'ai jamais
fait auparavant et ce fut une
expérience incroyable de revenir  temps
pourquoi suis-je différent
[Musique]
c'est tout simplement remarquable de pouvoir voir
les mouvements et la performance entrer
directement dans le personnage et c'est
comme s'il y avait Kate et hé il y avait
Renault donc ça m'a fasciné
qu'est-ce que c'est fait de
ce qui est  ce que
je trouve en tant que réalisateur je suis beaucoup plus à l'
écoute des acteurs parce que c'est tout ce dont
je dois m'inquiéter je ne suis pas distrait
par le mouvement de la caméra ou les figurants en
arrière-plan je suis juste là pour eux
c'est tout ce qui m'importe  c'est un  Je
regarde c'est un processus incroyable c'est
aussi la seule façon de le faire c'est la seule
façon de faire ce film
[Musique]